you know but I mean that has been like
one of the biggest things that I wanted
to bring out and share with the world
you know especially trying to be a
thought leader and working on their Evan
and you know his whole team I'm like I
can't come into this program in a lie
you know what I believe nation I'm
standing outside my studio here trying
to dance salsa for my first three day
workshop we are helping fad leaders
learn how to make money using their
ideas and I'm pretty excited we got
people flying in from Canada United
States Europe to be here for three days
and this is a new potential business
model and path for me I'm gonna see what
kind of feedback we get from doing this
how much I enjoy it and like it but the
goal is to take 15 thought leaders and
help them pick what's in here and push
it out to the world in a way that is
powerful and so I'm really pumped help
them out
[Music]
it's Doug Loffler I'm a career
firefighter 236 years found out about
the seminar actually was watching an
Evan video at 6:00 a.m. in the morning
and that popped up and I said I gotta go
and here we are
Mike Bellamy I'm a 19 year fireman down
in Tallahassee Florida have a little bit
of a background in public relations and
communications don't kind of introduce
me to to heaven I love following some of
the guys that are kind of connected with
Evan so you know this was a chance to
get to kind of learn whom he was the
last couple weeks kind of get caught up
and then they come here and just engross
the beautiful thing is that literally
walk in we wanted to get here early that
was our goal right and we beat heaven
here so that was huge
oh yeah because he challenged just said
you guys better be early well we meet
Evan somebody accomplished that right
off the bat we're gonna start at 9 we
got a warm-up and so what I want
everybody does come up we're gonna leave
your stuff come up to the front welcome
space yourself out here yeah
suit yourselves like a straight line in
a straight line across come a little bit
forward so you're not against the table
and you have the privilege of being with
the world's greatest dance instructor
because we're gonna learn a couple of
moves you learn a couple but chata moves
this morning to get our energy going
yeah
[Music]
No
[Music]
cool guys it's often how everybody here
this was a test you mind hitting the
fence Alex Thanks
this was a experiment for me you know a
lot of the stuff that I do is is mass
like I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs I want to help the world's
biggest problem I want to hit scale with
everything that I do I either go that or
I go super one-on-one working with Alex
working with Lilly work with J and
that's it and like nothing in between so
this is this is a test this is the
in-between it's like if I get you guys
for three days what kind of damage can
we do how much can we move you we are a
lot of content to go through today is
knowledge dump day we're going to try to
get everything that's in here and in in
there and there and there out into your
heads
tomorrow will be execution so we're
gonna be doing stories Instagram
snapchat we're gonna be doing your
foundation store gonna be filming it I'm
gonna be coaching you through that
process because it's not just about the
data it's about the doing my goal today
is to get the information out of my head
into yours we're gonna be talking a lot
of different topics but I also wanted to
be informal the reason why it's a tight
group is because I want to be able to
help each and every one of you so this
is a question that comes up like put up
your hand and let's go through it
because a lot of the information is
available I want to customize it to your
problem so as I'm talking through some
things let's get at it I was when I
found believe I didn't know I was
looking for one word or they didn't know
the process I just happened to come
across a couple of the businesses that
had done it I was I was inspired by it I
thought the one word idea was too simple
too basic there was a lot of limiting
beliefs to for me of Who am I to be the
belief guy you know such a big word but
that's the point is your mission should
be powerful should be important right
how often we talk ourselves down from
the Big Ideas not even waiting for
somebody else to tell us that we suck
it's ourselves saying I can't do this
big thing I applied it
I applied belief first to my newsletter
and for those of you who are still in
the process of finding it or you may not
have fully embraced it and put it out
there to the world I'm a big fan of just
testing like test this every actual bit
of information you get from today test
it try it on a small scale before
all in I want to make sure you're
getting value from it because time is
the thing that is most valuable to us so
I tested with my newsletter I just made
a newsletter but believe and it didn't
be my best newsletter in three or four
years the highest open rates the highest
click-through rates the highest number
of responses my sister wrote back to me
and said I like your newsletters now
it's like you know the the the punch the
stomach and pat on the back that only
like a sister can give you and then I
made the I made a video on my youtube
channel around belief like hey we'll do
another test they worked on the
newsletter but I don't know if it's
gonna work everywhere else we made one
video on it and I don't know if you guys
have seen the first believe videos that
the kind of early days of my youtube
channel we made this video that was six
and a half minutes long I really loved
it it was all about believers about the
Roger Valentine's story the four-minute
mile first gotta break it the people in
my network a lot of them didn't like it
said it was too long people who are in
the video industry said it was too long
you'd agree there should be a minute
long max you don't have attention spans
and I said well whatever I'm just gonna
post it who carries it with tanks of
tanks I like it so we're gonna post it
and it quickly became my best video on
the channel my previous best video had a
hundred thousand views in a year which I
was so proud of behind a thousand views
in a year I'm making a six figures on
the views it's awesome this one did a
hundred thousand views in a month and
then now is a two million or something
that's just it keeps going and so like
anything that I touch your own beliefs
is just does better and it's not because
believe is the best word which is
because it's me everybody's one word is
a powerful positive thing it's something
that is with the positive intent I've
never had anybody come and say my one
word is destruction
or hatred or right it's always like an
aspirational positive thing the
challenge is I think a lot of you guys
have the information like you you guys
have the knowledge right it's thought
leaders that's why you're here you have
the knowledge there's a lot of knowledge
out there the thing that will get people
on board is the energy that you bring
with it right you can walk people
through and tell them exactly what to do
it doesn't mean they're gonna do it and
so the thing that will get them going is
the energy so some of you have been
following on snapchat and Instagram and
YouTube we have sent me some stuff and
checked out your content I think one of
the things that's missing the biggest
challenge now is to talk a little about
it later on today it's just the
emotional commitment to what you're
saying
emotion on itself is not enough and so
one of the major lessons I want to start
you off with is it's gotta have a hero's
journey leaving someone on a low point
which is one of the things that I
struggle with like I would tell a really
deep emotional story but I didn't leave
them in the place of discomfort or pain
people can't get out of it and so I do
believe that you should be like if
you're struggling I'm struggling guys I
buh-buh-buh-buh but even saying
something like I'm strong so if I said
I'm so super nervous about doing this
and so I'm like you need something for
success to me all the time like what do
I know
and so I happen to word belong here
right now written and so I'm considering
getting a tattoo and I'm really
uncomfortable tattoos by the way like
mark is something my body blue so this
is a test attitude and when I was
sitting down looking up the word belong
and I was like I belong anywhere as long
as I don't betray myself
I just need to come on it just beat me
and I think that's my biggest strength
to be honest I think that we under play
but that's your biggest strength I watch
Tony Robbins I watch all these people
who speak Publix because then I tried to
imitate them every time I tried to be as
loud as Tony Robbins and I did this in
class and in ball so what a my first
experiment was I did this racial quote I
was crazy about special cold so I'd be
like blah blah blah you know you can
swim or whatever this matter so I'd see
this form a lot like Tony Robbins right
and I bring the energy up and she's like
very jealous Bob before like it's
aggressive it's uncomfortable but
honestly it's because I was crap up
doing it and it wasn't me
[Music]
[Music]
first of all I mean the love and yeah
this whole couple of days is about
taking action and really making it real
for all of you so I'm going to pick on a
couple of volunteers
one person actually volunteered already
yeah so right here she's she's she's
like I'm gonna do this follow me
it was super know via Facebook but today
I want to share with you my one word my
one word this past Easter the reason why
I choose this part is I was a teenager
one went in a Tamar one not home you
know I had my baby when I was 18 years
old I was pregnant by 17 years old and
my son is 18 amazing it gives me
emotional because we're come from it was
it cool and I had to go through some
stuff to ice it was a really hard to be
in class with people while younger than
me so this word is my soul and it's what
I carry through my moment my financial
education is to teach you guys to always
be persistent never give up
it's me something to meet commit to
whatever you start never give up
persevere that's my second one and
really it comes from self believing
myself that I can't do it so I take that
every day
opt to my goal but surely every day to
learn about finance but you also this
one comes from being that teenager mom
that had to go through struggling with
self belief and that's my wonder why I'm
so excited
hey don't water wine and every
Carmichael's plus I've been asked by
Lily to talk about vision what it means
to be the reason vision is so important
to me is because it's forward thinking
it's looking at the future is trying to
make something happen
the other part is this community is the
fact that community is so important and
sharing the vision and getting people to
go along the journey to get out of their
comfort zone to say I'm jumping in the
deep end without water wings it's it's
the ability to look back and challenge
the norm and trying to get naysayers the
haters people saying you can't do it and
it says you know watch me so that's the
vision peace out
[Music]
so there's a lot of please and I feel
like I have to create because I didn't
have a lot of warship in my life a
pretty broad pretty well maintained I
have like the average problem you know
being the middle child there is the
middle child syndrome if you're a middle
child or you [ __ ] oh yeah so you know
the challenges are being ignored
so being ignored what do you do in
business you create and so I don't have
any kids I try not to attach myself to
too many commitments I like to create
produce in his leg flourish and watch it
grow it made me health benefit in their
process that's how I knew I was an
entrepreneur as photographer all my
magical things became my babies and I
felt like I was creating this pack for
them because not only was I taking
pictures but I was actually guiding them
into you know like I was inspiring him
to do you know something big with their
life because I would always tell my
story about no one believed in me
because steel took today people think
that being a photographer is just you
know ha you know especially with all the
cell phones out but you know improving
around because now today you know I have
to air bleeds
and company ID and I have a new
marketing too you know so so many people
are like how are you doing all the same
I don't know like I don't even ask a
question how are you know if I can do it
or why my ability I just create I don't
like look up anything I don't I don't
look towards the negative I just do like
I want to do something I get to do
something I just go and do it
that's my word create you know just do
it don't overthink it
don't over you know analyze it just go
ahead and do it and watch your life
change I'm because I'm a living
testimony welcome back we're still
waiting on a couple people now I've got
I was I want to lead off with a surprise
but we're not doing the dancing even
alex is surprised right okay I need I
need Alex that come with it and he's not
gonna tattoo I need ox come to the front
and I need I need Tam to come to the
front
okay and and okay okay okay
okay hold her hand okay no not like not
dancing trace the front face them and
just you could just hold you there you
go okay are even you know what go go
like there we go okay okay okay let's go
for this go stage Center okay she has a
very important story to share people
promised girl nightingale
Kaleo and he was saying you know if you
you know train the mind to believe a lie
you will really you believe it you
actually believe it so from that point
on I became 30 14 years so I confessed
to Evan that I was 42 okay yeah and I
have been living this you know not lie
but kind of a deception you know by me
confessing that hey I came to say the
number again
but I mean being 42 I can you know you
may not be a big deal to some people and
I know some people are living like this
a big deal but I have nothing in common
with anyone my age because my lifestyle
is not the same I don't kill nightmares
I still relate to everyone back in high
school I miss all my high school reunion
because of this you know this issue
I probably avoided a lot of you know
huge events in my life because of this
issue so you know under I know they told
me back so today I'm moving forward and
I'm confessing you know and changing my
mission to help all those who are in my
tribe are in my position to pay is still
not to make it you know guarantee is 42
you know he's doing amazing things and I
I need to give a little more context
okay so so she stops me at the break the
lunch break and she's like I have a I
have a secret to tell and at some point
today and I have to tell you the secret
but I know it's coming in will we'll see
at some point like okay tell me what's
up right now no I can't do it right now
okay okay we like go to the corner yeah
yeah she wanted to talk quietly in the
corner and and started crying saying the
story it's like I'm what's just telling
this huge backstory and then just okay
what is it I'm 42 I think that's it
right mine is like huge but so telling
me was already a big deal but listen -
wait you just told all of these people
but but your it was way harder to tell
me than to tell them so it's harder it's
harder to tell me what the point is just
like just like Alex's story of just
telling one person then it's easy to
tell everybody like telling me was
difficult telling the first person is
hard but now now in a group of people
she just met today she's expressing the
biggest fear and insecurity she has that
people back home don't even know about
and in in every every time you bring it
up is gonna be easier to tell over the
years the mind is so powerful if you
believe in it with when there's a liar
night you will believe it and so I
thought I was in my 30s
you know and so it's always come through
my actions oh yeah you know talking
speaking
I'm just trying to fit in so it's just a
lot deeper than that yeah but I mean
that on a surface I know just me
releasing that one secret it's gonna
help me with a lot of other things the
the pain will lead to the purpose right
the purpose comes from the pain and so
by sharing the vulnerabilities that
allows people to learn through your
story right and people now be more open
to sharing their vulnerabilities with
you and what I said was hey you got
inspired by Alex's story you need to
tell him because alex is one orders
belong he made you feel belong enough
that you wanted to come up and tell me
this huge secret of yours so you have to
tell him because we're gonna make him
teary-eyed now because even if all of
these Punk's you know don't like it like
do it for Alex because the message was
so valuable to you that you were willing
to share it like you owe it to him to
say what that means to you so Alex
didn't know we were doing this he
thought he was gonna teach my bachata so
you got to do this instead so it's been
a great first day so many moving
conversations one of the things that
really came out from today is just how
block people are from the
judgement of other people they're afraid
to tell people how old they are they're
afraid of how to go off and take the
thing that's inside their head and just
execute just do it because you're
worried how someone is gonna judge you
and I think people aren't afraid of
failing they're afraid of failing in
front of somebody else and at some point
you need to decide if you're going to
live your life or somebody else's
version of your life and what we've been
able to unlock today which has been
fantastic is just that feeling that if
you can be vulnerable if you can share
your experiences it's actually
inspiration do you think that that makes
you look weak it's actually the thing
that breaks down all the walls that's
the thing that gives permission for
other people to share their experience
as well to share their vulnerabilities
with you as well and so if you want to
inspire all you want
well you want people to pick up a cause
you want people to learn how to be
themselves it's not going to come from
you being a fake version of you and so
letting go of the expectations that
other people put on you not accepting
them and some people will love you for
it listen some people may hate you for
it some people may disrespect you for it
it's okay at the end of the day you need
to live your version of your life and
not somebody else's stop living in the
fear of its most expert
hope you guys enjoyed this vlog I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where is much love sees him if you
tell yourself a story long enough you
start to believe it won't you believe it
you act like I have Tulsa what a wail
out of handcuffed lightning though
Thunder in jail now you know I'm bad on
the last week I murdered a rock into the
stone hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I
make medicine sick the fundamental key
to success is it can take between
eighteen and two hundred and fifty four
days of taking action for a new habit to
stick I've created a new course called
250 for confidence or every single day
for two hundred fifty four days I will
be sending you a video between thirty
seconds and five minutes long that you
start your morning with around making
you feel confident it's absolutely free
check out the link in the description
below to get access